so you were saying sammy right you were
talking about this yeah i had a question
for you guys because again brian's a big
fan all that mafia stuff he won't shut
up about it and he was talking about how
tough they are and i
propose the question are they actually
tough like tough like i guess what's
your definition of tough
well tough is if you do a street fight
one-on-one i mean it's not it's not even
a that's not the world
so you're not dealing with that kind of
tough
um
the tough of their world is
the amount of influence they have
and who they had in their pockets
and how much business they control but
you're talking power right that's powers
different very different of course it is
it's very different you know if you want
to go into a uh they're tough to go
against yeah like uh like the union but
i'm gonna tell you this so sammy's
sitting here adam's sitting here okay
the entire time adam he's six one adam's
an athlete adam was a he called me
skinny but whatever
i think we need to find the term athlete
as well
you guys are very loose with these by
the way
descriptions athlete tough the guy the
guy
the guy that's actually could be an
athlete these two guys play so him he's
the best uh they call him the best
jewish athlete out of miami i don't know
what that means but that's like being
like the tallest [ __ ] that's kind of
what that means
it's like winning gold in the special
exactly that's me right here yeah yeah
pretty easy
so we go to dinner with sammy and then
we do a podcast and adam decides to ask
a question from sammy uh would you say
sesame so you've been around the block
for a while yeah yeah but let's use your
knowledge of history to our advantage
here because whoa you [ __ ] call me
older what are you like but how how old
is he he's 70. mid-70s are we doing that
yeah yeah
i'm like
yeah exactly what i will tell you so i
haven't interviewed a lot of them there
was one guy frank collada i don't know
if you've seen the movie casino if
you've seen the movie casino frank
yeah he wasn't so frank colada is
do you know when the scene casino where
they go and he puts a guy's head in a
vice versa
he's like that's the name that's who
you're saving yeah that frank colada i
interviewed when he walked into the room
it's
cold as ice you felt his spirit
capable
capable not like this but kpop cable
like this capable in many different ways
doesn't make it tough but here's the
thing though it makes you a sociopath
but let me ask you though that's like
saying like our wide receiver's tough
because they're not going to beat up a
offensive lineman and a you know
physical
yeah but i'm just saying there's there's
different spots on the team everybody
has a role to play but but there are
some receivers that put it on you man
then there's no matter what you are so
let me ask you guys if you played in the
nfl yeah you okay
again we're loose with the turnbull
i just want to be very clear i had a
cappuccino with the buffalo bills and
then they're like we're all set on slow
white how good was that makes sense how
good was the cappuccino uh not good okay
very sour and short so so question
question if we if you if you measure
toughness you're talking sportsier
if you measure toughness what sport
would you say produces the toughest guys
this is for sports not even a question
hockey four sports nfl nhl nba go from
the toughest to the lowest stuff nba's
least the least yeah they're divas yeah
they're because they're they're pedigree
like when they're like 13 you know
they're getting rainbows and [ __ ]
they've been rich
ahead of nhl
here's here's why nhl doesn't count
they're all white guys okay it's like
like when you tell me they're missing
teeth though i mean i know but they're
on ice and they're in canada that's all
there is to it
and also it's not a worldwide you're
allowed to have a boxing match in the
middle of your fridge
you just you just said the nhl is not a
worldwide sport but the nfl and the nba
are no well nba is for sure
half the people in the nhl got nothing
but continents in their name they all
come from northern sweden they've come
from sweden
you're about to get a lot of nordic hate
there brenda oh no i don't want that
the nh the point is they're all white
you know what i'm saying what do you
mean by that what do you mean when you
say they're all white it's tough because
if you look at basketball like it's a
global sport soccer's global sport
fighting's a global sport so you're
getting the best of the very best in nhl
as soon as black guys are like what the
is this a pair of skates they're [ __ ]
all those european and white guys are
fighting
breaking news that's not happening
anytime soon well never say never okay
we'll see we'll see how that happens
you're saying there could be a major
search of uh uh if they want just go
into hockey
yeah you know those black guys skating
out there you know they're they're
coming for your nascar driver yeah
ranger's got keondre miller and ryan
reeves man here we go there you go we're
on on the way to the cup obviously
that logic the range is already
happening
we've left one sport out so it's
basically nhl at the top we put nfl at
the top
no i i'll agree angel nhl they're pretty
[ __ ] tough on the amount of strain
and then also their schedule the work
schedule is a beast okay so you put nhl
nfl so now the debates between mlb and
nba so who is it
nbc is dead mlb is yeah mlb so you had a
good story you told yesterday about one
time when you hit this bomb that you hit
this homer in the in uh
yeah yeah yeah uh there was it was a
brawl
it was a bra i guess i'm the only guy
that ever got uh a nine-game suspension
for a home run that didn't count and i
hit a home run it's a long long story
did you start brad isn't it like frowned
upon if you like flip the battery that's
right
it's called entertainment yeah
yeah well this is the thing it was it
was cub scout day at the stadium so the
the commissioner was pretty pissed off
that we started a 45-minute brawl at no
with nothing but five thousand cub stats
that makes sense
in the in the stands so yeah basically
what happened was there was an old
pitcher named juan brazelton he was a
first draft pick yeah he was a first
round draft pick he's from florida tough
dude and um you know he got he got a
little chatty with me i got a little
chatty back at him he threw a fastball
wasn't fast enough i enjoyed it in a
little bit too long i guess and his
catcher decided to punch me in the face
when i came across home plate and then
the bench is cleared bench is cleared i
was about to get absolute i was about to
get absolutely destroyed the entire
dugout for them comes out ready to come
and get me as i'm tussling on the ground
with their catcher and i'm literally at
this point i've got them in hole and i'm
thinking like oh [ __ ] and then antonio
alfonseka google this dude is this all
like dominic intro dude he was an
all-star in the big leagues he's down
here with us he's like six eight four
hundred pounds he's got six fingers on
both hands six toes el poopo ray and out
of nowhere this this angel this giant
dominican 400 pound angel comes swooping
in and tackles their entire team before
they get to me this guy saved your life
i owe everything i have to this day
gerard were you this antonio
no i was beautiful i was uh i was just
that'd be the biggest baseball player
that was 200 offensive guard 225 pounds
of beautiful did you play football too
or no yeah yeah yeah
yeah i played football so well they let
me play baseball makes sense so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]